after 17 is rolling two connected things
in together one is kind of a big picture
historical grand movement kind of kind
of item and the other one has to do with
a particular denominational family and
we haven't talked about yet the
Baptist's and if you're going to look at
the Americans religious landscape right
now you would probably want to start
with the Baptist's along with the
Catholics in part because the largest
religious body in the United States
right now that the Roman Catholic Church
second largest is a Southern Baptist
Convention and a few of the other
Baptist Convention's are in the top 10
as well the national baptist convention
national baptist convention corporated
and then there's a few other baptist
bodies that are also pretty large and
you know you remember from that chapter
that that Baptists were actually a very
tiny tiny group in early America they
didn't they didn't have a huge role
that's fine it's always going to be some
noise going on so what we're going to be
interested in here is where did they
come from first off because there's a
lot of different origin stories and then
what made the bat just want me then
distinctively a tradition and how do
they end up growing how did they end up
becoming important part of the landscape
so let's start with this question where
they come from and your book actually
doesn't go into this too much it just
gives you one of the answers but if you
ask within Baptist communities you will
sometimes get other views about this and
one of these is what's called the
succession as you think back to gospel
stories you know and they can think
about Baptists why are Baptists so you
know why is that the act of baptism so
important anybody remember from like
Sunday school or CCD year things like
that why don't you really Christians
think this was important yeah give it a
very
that's the sort of an explanation later
on that comes in that's very important
yeah only how John knew Jesus was sewn
together if there's that incident yeah
and you know John is Jesus's cousin and
he's all out there preaching already
he's on wilderness and saying with pads
and he's baptizing all these people
these people that is baptizing our
Jewish he may have been tightened at the
s seeing movement we're not really a
traditional people people theories one
way of dealing Jesus comes to him and
your reg is that you know John loses
heavens open up incident and John gives
way basically to Jesus after he baptizes
him and so they became a central act for
Christians for each for nearly all the
Protestants despite what they may have
gotten rid of from previous church
traditions they held on to that very
firmly and some of the Baptist would say
that they actually could trace their
roots back to John the Baptist that
there is a succession of churches going
all the way back historically there's no
evidence and it's a minority of you
among Baptist but there are some still
who ain't a map to this day did the
Baptist come from the Anabaptists you
know the name would kind of suggests
that the practice of baptizing as adults
would kind of suggests that so some
people actually thought the Baptist did
in fact come you know sort of like a
direct route from the Anabaptist but we
know is it's not actually the case
they're actually coming from the
Puritans and they're coming from the
Puritans in England what kind of gives
you the impression that they're starting
out here in the United States but the
movement really strictly speaking is
getting started in England yeah when we
talk about the some of the differences
with the Puritans some of them were like
strict separatists you gotta separate
the church from the state altogether
Church of England is totally corrupt
others thought you could kind of reform
it from within
purify it so these are some of the
separatists the Puritans he and what's
peculiar to them is this this emphasis
on baptism on baptism of adults most of
the Puritans stuck to the old reform to
view which was that you know if there's
one thing that the Catholics on that you
know the Anglican Lutheran's didn't get
wrong it was that children should be
baptized you know as infants so these
guys actually they don't get a lot of
traction efforts there a tiny tiny
sliver of real minority movement and
your book then talks about somebody who
played an important role in American
history this guy Roger Williams you'll
remember back when I was talking about
the Puritans when we're looking at that
in an earlier chapter and so that Rhode
Island was kind of a haven if you
couldn't fit into the Puritan way of
life they would kick you out if they
disliked you enough he had a lot of the
people that they kicked out went off to
Rhode Island which at that time was more
or less a wilderness you know now it's
pretty nice there's a lot of posh places
and in some parts of it but back then it
was it was you know another place you
could go and that's where you would go
if you didn't fit in religiously so a
lot of these separatists Baptists that's
where they ended up finding their place
and like your book points out for a
while it's just two just two churches
there's not much going on with Baptist
life was rather sleepy combined to the
two venerable churches and Providence
and Newport the two main cities of Rhode
Island and a few scattered congregations
this great awakening that we're talking
about that's what gets them moving and
the Baptist then start getting very
enthusiastic about the revival some of
the main traits of the Great Awakening
are things that become very important
for Baptist spirituality and then you
get a couple other distinctions coming
and that your book talks about these
aren't that important for understanding
who the badges are today because they
don't generally think in these terms
they are important for understanding the
history of the Baptist's in the United
States and the things that divided
Baptist from one another some of the
things you get one of the main things
that's going to find on the slavery
actually but they talk about separate
suburbs and general and particular
Baptists now the general in particular
that's referring to a split that's
taking place in theology between a
minion or free will views and Calvinists
remember they were Puritans originally
so they're Calvinists plus the central
baptist statutes refers to this sort of
tradition of you know churches should be
completely separate from the civil order
they tend to be part of what's called
the free church movement yeah the free
church movement tends to view things
sort of like like this this is very
characteristic of Baptists you have
individual churches and those churches
each one of them is its own units each
one of them has its own congregation its
own way of doing things what happens in
this church is not necessarily
reflective of what's going to happen in
this church if they believe some
doctrine over here you don't like that
doctrine that's fine just don't go to
the church go to this one over here now
if those churches want to get together
into an organization that's okay that's
what's called in Baptist turns over time
a convention so you hear about southern
baptist convention that's a huge
association of all these churches
nowadays it's done at the state level
and then at the national level alright
so the Southern Baptist Convention
a bunch of state conventions together
and each of those is a whole bunch of
churches but if a church decides they
don't like what's going on with this
higher level of authority they just they
say fine we're going our own particular
way the separate Baptists never really
formed together they always remain sort
of you know not disintegrated not
disorganized but they just thought that
things are better handled at the
Congregational level their word
associations in the general and
particular Baptist your book talks about
some of the interplay between them
there's a lot in quite a lot of bad
blood between them as well because
they're they're arguing over issues of
salvation over who is actually saved and
who isn't and at how you have to live in
order to be a Christian now one thing
that you can say it is the last thing
that I'll say about Baptists at this
point about all these groups all these
Baptist groups is that remember when I
talked about methodism being a very
portable religion being easy to take out
to the frontier think about Baptist
Christianity that way as well if you
don't have to have bishops and you don't
have to have you know an official
doctrine that every church has to agree
to and you don't even have to have some
sort of organized system of education
and each congregation can do its own
thing it's very easy to start a new
church isn't it you just you know send
it to people out it up to the frontier
and build a building get together bring
a few Bibles that might be home right
and now you've got a church and so as
opposed to some of the other churches
like the Lutheran's or the Anglicans or
even the Presbyterians where it was
harder to move it out to the American
frontier the Baptist's the Methodists
they could get out there immediately and
they were sort of follow the movement
along the frontier so as the population
is shifting westward those airy well and
also southward into you know the Apple
and southern colonies those areas are
being developed let's say religiously by
the congregations that are there the
denominations that can move out easier
particularly the Baptist so we see
incredible growth among Baptists in the
seventeenth and eighteenth as the
seventeen hundreds of 18 degrees not the
seventeenth and eighteenth century but
the eighteenth and nineteenth century no
I talked about the Baptist first in part
because I wanted to get them out of the
way as a denomination let's talk now
about this Great Awakening business so
this is a movement that's taking place
in America it's got some roots and other
places as well but it's taking place
within the churches that are already
there and already established and it's
taking place across churches so it's not
just a Puritan thing it's not just a
Presbyterian thing it's not just an
Anglican thing or Methodist thing all
these people are talking back and forth
to each other you can think of it in a
certain way is like a second Protestant
Reformation the book doesn't use doesn't
go quite that far and talking about it
that way but you can think of it like
that there's this an incredible sense of
huge changes taking place he and your
book mentions a number of important
people at a number of different aspects
to this so one of the key things we've
talked about this before is the tension
between the heart and the head the Great
Awakening was about a religion of the
heart and what would have that involved
with you know we spell this out a little
bit last class or in the class before
what are you associate with the heart
besides Valentine's Day
hey cupid do you say there's a cupid
yeah that makes sense you know again
that's part of the Valentine's Day
imagery what does keep it dude yeah now
love is what something that drives you
crazy i'm looking for the general thing
that it fits into what is what is what
emotion and emotions right so they talk
in terms of little affections the term
that we use today is emotions and love
is is one of the emotions that they want
to cultivate it's not about you know
cultivating hate or anger or fear
necessarily although you know some of
them did focus quite a bit unfair of God
but it's about love it's about
compassion it's about feeling a
connection with other people and feeling
a connection with with God now just
thinking about connection not just
having faith in a connection but
actually feeling it so let's yeah let's
look at a few other things that they
talk about i'm going to skip over the
geographical stuff we can come back to
that they talked about this as being a
massive religious revival that sweeps
over the entire Atlantic coast he had
elevates the personal intense religious
experience of emotional here's another
important term conversion conversion is
turning to God and commensurately away
from some other things so what would you
you're converting what would you be
turning away from what you know when
people can convert they have a
conversion experience and they say I
found Jesus I know how to personal
relationship with Jesus what sort of
things aren't think you know at least
openly doing anymore you guys have
experience with this with people who
know saying I've had a religious
experience was that is that kind of
foreign tan
doesn't happen as much it certainly
doesn't happen like it did during the
Great Awakening when this was very
common away from however you I can see
the world the way from sin away from
world away from you know evil away from
from bad things and this is something
that's an intensely emotional it's also
very personal if I'm going to be
converted that has to happen for me and
the fact that he's converted doesn't
have anything to do with me necessarily
his relationship with God is his
relationship God mine is you know the
one that I am we could talk about it
maybe he could like enough enlighten me
about his own but ultimately it's up to
what I do but I feel what happens with
me yeah like your book mentions you know
in important movements like with Luther
Martin Luther had that kind of
experience and he wrote about it but
we're all Lutheran saying hey I gotta
have this experience with Martin Luther
no it's good enough that Luther had that
experience he had some insights that
came out of that and then they go on
with you know that that practice within
that tradition with this the emphasis is
different everybody should have this
everybody should experience themselves
their own conversion their own personal
emotive relationship with God now your
book talks about a few important people
involved with this and we talked about
one of these guys already or is his
family matter the pennants
they were Presbyterians and you remember
we talked about the law college is his
sermon the dangers of an unconverted
ministry he was pushing for this sort of
thing he was saying if you don't have
this kind of experience you probably
shouldn't be a preacher you shouldn't be
out there doing some you know and then
it talks about this guy trailing waysm
it's Dutch Reformed Minister not quite
so important because the Dutch Reformed
who not that representative and then it
talks about this guy I'm a big fan of
actually Jonathan Edwards Edwards is a
actually a Puritan he's the
congregation's and he's also the first
American philosopher in any real sense
he's I won't say the father of American
philosophy because neither to be
followed his views but he was a guy who
was very very well trained academically
he was a preacher he was a theologian he
was a philosopher he wrote a lot he
organized a lot he had a huge influence
and Edwards like it says his role in the
revival was really crucial he was one of
its most effective creatures he had a
congregation and he he wrote sermons
that we still have today as part of
American literature if you've ever read
the sinners in the hands of an angry god
which is a great read Fox but you know
the human being is like a spider
suspended over the fire by the hand of
God and who knows why God isn't throwing
us in there very very imagistic very
very stark right and the idea is to try
to produce this conversion experience so
he's a he's an important preacher he
wants to bring about a change of
consciousness and his listeners he's
focused on the emotions he actually
writes a whole book about the religious
emotions hold on the religious
affections and he tries to use imagery
metaphor so that's part of what makes
him such a great literary think
he's also somebody life John Wesley was
very good at organizing things if you
want to have a movement it's not enough
to have some great ideas you actually
have to have some organizational
capacity the kind of things that we
actually teach about in business classes
or in organizational psychology classes
a lot of people have a kind of native
skill for this and Edwards is one of
those now what he did is he developed
like that the book says in classic form
a sort of restatement of the essentials
of calvinism in a philosophical form
that that reflected his thought and
experience from would lead to this sort
of sort of thing Edwards also focused
very much on the relationship between
God and the individual the Puritans have
been talking about covenants remember a
covenant isn't a sort of agreement
between people so if we're 21 Puritan
church what you do over there reflects
on me because we're all in a covenant
together with God and we're all in a
covenant together with each other with
Edwards you're sort of taking out the
middleman it's much more about the
individuals relationships with with God
so he's a major player and then the guy
who were sort of like going from I
should i should actually be going from
you know the bottom to the top as we go
in order of importance we have this
other guy George Whitfield would feel
and Whitfield is all over the map he
starts out as an Anglican has an intense
conversion experience like this sees a
lot of other people having that sort of
stuff he was an extraordinarily gifted
preacher you know you may it when you
read this in your book you may think we
know those people were a bunch of rubes
or suckers when you when you hear that
you could reduce an audience to tears
simply by pronouncing the word
Mesopotamia but he appeared you have
some sort of charisma he could take a
crowd and just hold them in the palm of
his hand you know some people are just
excellent speakers you can listen to
them all day long you find yourself even
if you disagreed with them at the start
sort of agreeing after a while he was
one of those guys and even Benjamin
Franklin found himself Benjamin Franklin
is a hardcore you know pretty secular
guy Benjamin Franklin by the way like
him to do a lot of things that we don't
normally think of him doing you should
read about him sometimes Vicki he was
actually involved in a lot of different
things besides just electricity and
independence he was even almost
converted by West Hill so that's going
pretty [ __ ] whitefield revolutionizes
preaching and he you know when somebody
comes on the scene and they managed to
really hold the public's attention and
do something new what happens after that
you get a lot of imitators don't you a
lot of people said that's the way to go
Whitfield's example influences
generations of preachers down to the day
down to this day particularly Anabaptist
so woodfield woodfield like it says was
known as the grand it the tinner end the
creature who who goes from place to
place the place that just wasn't done in
that in those days you might if you were
a preacher you might go to somebody
else's church but you would go there by
envy
asian you would be wandering around
looking for people just to you know
listen to you wherever you went that was
kind of frowned upon and what we'll talk
about why in just a moment so whitfield
like your book points out is really an
enlarged respect America's first
celebrity you guys well heard that even
the phrase famous for being famous said
about Paris Hilton the mouth said about
all sorts of people what feels the first
person you can say that about in America
a lot of people who didn't know him knew
of him and then wanted to know him and
so he could go pretty much anywhere he
wanted and find a following in part
because it was great gifts in part
because what he was doing is catching up
so now there were several different main
features of the preaching that's that's
taking place and Whitfield is
responsible for some of these the
tenants are also responsible for some of
these your book talks about I like this
word sends Furius what is it you guys
know this term to censure to Center
somebody bad and that happens to you it
means that some organized body is saying
we don't like this guy he's done such
and such things like the Senate's and
censure you and I think the house of
representatives can I don't know
somebody's a poli-sci major fill me in
on whether that's the case it's not like
disciplining you it's more like saying
here event you know you're bad for these
reasons George tenant was saying that
about other preachers he was saying that
about the religious establishment he was
saying look unless you've had this
conversion experience unless you have
this passion driving your preaching
you're no good so you can imagine that
didn't go over all that well with many
people right because when you tell
people that they're doing the wrong
thing how do they usually react to you
do they you just I'm so happy that you
filled me in now I know exactly what I
should be doing
you thank you for that is that is that
your ordinary experience what would you
guys more generally experience how do
people react yeah usually pretty
defensive and are their own view just
about why they're right yeah that's a
good term for defensive they see you as
attacking them not as trying to help
them out because just attacking them and
then they will often go on the attack
with you and that's that's part of
what's happening with this there's a few
other important features so we have this
this I always miss spell this word
tineret preaching so that's wandering
around in place to place another thing
that's tied in with this is lei
preaching and when is you this term lage
think lady think about the the people
who haven't been to seminary the people
they don't have special treat our
training they just have some sort of
calling or gift or feeling that they
should be preaching so any of you could
be a lay preacher even though you don't
have a theology degree I don't maybe
some of you do have the theology suspect
not all would take for you is for you to
feel like you were actually called do so
and then they talk about ex temporary
preaching you guys know this where this
temporary is coming from laughingstocks
unusual x temporary preaching is when
you're you don't have a sec lecture in
front you just start you say today we're
going to talk about this this incident
in the Gospel of John and you just start
talking and you start connecting things
together in academics it would be
certain how many of you have to do
present
and classes so many classes do you like
doing presentations no why not yeah
because when you shook your head so
vehemently ah I like all came from
people that's a big one ch a lot of
people you can get over that if you do
it enough but it takes a while what why
else don't you like doing presentations
it or is that the main reason are there
other reasons you don't want to do it ya
know you're talking that's that's a big
one you really have to know what you're
talking about or else somebody's going
to say hey do youdo not be talking about
and maybe the you know professor gives
you a bad grade or students make fun
over here or something like that any
other reasons too yeah I'd only doing it
with grooves is I can't control what
other people say yeah Steve you know
professors are convinced that students
love group work students hate group work
for a variety of reasons I don't need a
generalized model but there's always
someone who doesn't do their job and
yeah you're right you can't control what
other people are going to say now in
this case if you were if you were the
preacher you're the only guy up there so
that wouldn't be so much of an issue but
that you know that fear of public
speaking or reticence about it that need
to really know what you're talking about
most preachers at that time would have a
written sermon they would write it out
beforehand that's why we have their
sermons and then they would read it they
were just get up there and read through
the whole thing imagine like it if
today's lecture was just me opening okay
everyone open the text book to page 141
you'll now begin with the Great
Awakening and the Baptist tradition take
the rise and spread and PI identity and
methodism along both and whether the now
managed I do this in a monotone you know
there would be a long hour wouldn't it
if you do know what you're talking about
and in order to talk about conversion
you'd actually have to count a
conversion right if you do know what
you're talking about you
speak extemporary you can talk at length
about things and start putting things
together on the fly George Whitfield was
a expert at this there's a lot of other
people who are good at this and you know
for a lot of Christian churches it would
be crazy to bring in a sermon that's
written out that would be a sign that
you really don't know your stuff that it
hasn't become part of who you are that
you're not you know sees one of those
the phrase is on fire for the word so
this was all this is a new style of
being a preacher a new style of doing
things this leads to lot of splits in
religious denominations talks about the
old side of the new side the old lights
the new lights generally the old are
going to be the ones who are not in
favor of doing this very emotional kind
of stuff and the new ones are the ones
who are in favor um so sometimes it
actually led the splits and in the
particular churches so your book talks
about blushing what did this actually
pan out guys what did what did this turn
into it affected religious life in all
the guy variations and it left these
lasting marks a new conception of how
the person who's doing the preaching
want to be behaving luscious means
there's going to be a second great
awakening coming after this this shakes
things up in a lot of denominations so
we'll see how this plays out as we go
into other chapters